dans un pays lointain deux tailleurs
s'apprêta escroqué un empereur très
soucieux de son apparence
l'effis louvre ont dû promettre des
vêtements qui resteront invisible aux
imbéciles un compte sur le conformisme
que la compagnie qu'elle aspirait à
jouer depuis longtemps en truc c'est une
histoire qui est toujours d'actualité
est de plus en plus aujourd'hui tout est
mis sur la com mais il faut toujours
paraître il faut toujours faire des
tonnes pour montrer à quel point on est
super on est génial et c est ce qui se
passe vraiment après cependant pas très
important pour adapter ce conte
d'andersen
les marionnettistes de la compagnie
escales ont opté pour le théâtre
d'ombrés un jeu scénique auquel très peu
de troupes se prête en europe
c'est une contrainte spatiale terrible
parce que l'on le théâtre donc c'est un
théâtre de profil donc nous on a cherché
dans notre pièce à trouver des liens
entre l'ombre à deux dimensions et
l'acteur physique en trois dimensions et
donc on a travaillé des masques qui sont
des masques de profilés qui peuvent du
coup exister et dans londres et est en
réalité ce culturellement mais
effectivement c'est des contraintes très
fortes avec lesquels on joue parce que
finalement à l'intérieur de cette
multitude de contraintes précises de
placement direction d'orientation etc il
y à une étincelle de jeu qu'il faut
aller chercher les habits neufs de
l'empereur c'est l'un des 23 spectacles
programmés au festival international de
marionnettes de vendôme des
divertissements pour les petits et les
grands
à voir sur toute la région
[Musique]